where we left off in the last video we
were beginning to try to figure out what
the 24 roots of one were and then we're
going to square those 24 roots take the
absolute value of their imaginary part
and then sum them up so let's once again
let's just think about the roots that
matter so this over here we figured out
this is pi over 12. so let me this is pi
over 12 as the angle i guess i should
say that's e to the pi over 12 i let me
just focus on the angle here this over
here is 2 pi over 12 or pi over 6 this
over here is 3 pi over 12 or pi over 4
this over here is 4 pi over 12
4 pi over 12 or pi over 3 and this right
over here is 5 pi over 12.
this right over here is 5 pi over 12 and
then this obviously is 6 pi over 12 or
pi over 2 we could keep going but before
we keep going and this is this will
really just simplify the math a little
bit remember we have to square these
roots so let's just think about if we
have some complex number a plus bi
if we have some complex number a plus bi
let's think about what happens when we
square it this is going to be equal to a
squared plus 2 a
b i
minus b squared or we could rewrite it
as a squared minus b squared will be the
real part and then plus 2 a b i 2 a b is
the imaginary part
and the reason why i even took the
trouble of writing it this way is to
realize that the comp what we're going
to do is going to square all these
complex numbers and then take the
absolute value of the imaginary part so
really all that matters is the absolute
value all that matters the absolute
value of 2av or really 2 times the
absolute value 2 times the absolute
value of a b
now these guys all have analogs where
either a or b would be negative so if
this guy is
if this guy
this right over here is let's call this
a plus bi if you had a minus bi you
would be down here you would be down
here so this guy is a plus bi a minus bi
is going to be over here or you could
have negative a minus bi is going to be
over here negative a minus bi is going
to be over there or you could have
negative a plus bi over here
negative a plus bi over here but the
reason why i did this is we showed you
just over here all of these guys when
you square them and you take the
absolute value of the imaginary part of
that squared value it's all going to be
the same because when you take it's
going to be a b
absolute value is just going to be a b
negative a b absolute values are still
going to be a b so they're all going to
be the same so what we can do is and
each of these guys are going to have the
same analog so what we could do is just
find the values for these guys one two
three four for these five guys over here
and then just multiply whatever we get
by four because they each have
i guess there's four of these around the
unit circle and that'll save a lot of
our work now the other thing we want to
think about we already said that we have
to ignore one because we added that root
but even if we didn't remember it
ignored it wouldn't matter because one
square one doesn't have an imaginary
part one squared is still one does not
have an imaginary part we can also
ignore we can also ignore
we can also ignore an angle of pi over 2
or 90 degrees because this has no real
part and you see over here that when you
square it when you square it it's
actually going to take you over here and
it won't have any imaginary part when
you square it it's 2 times the real
times the imaginary part this has no
real part so this is going to be 0. so
this guy will also not contribute so we
really just care about these angles
right over here and then and then we'll
square them find the absolute value of
the imaginary parts and then we'll
multiply everything by four because that
will correspond to these other to their
to what if you took the a the imaginary
the real parts and made them negative
and it would take us all the way around
the unit circle so let's think about it
a little bit let me just write these
over here so the z's the z's that we'll
think about right now are going to be e
to the pi over
e to the pi over 12
e to the pi over
e to the pi over 6
e to the pi over 4 oh e to the pi over
12 i i should say pi over 6 i pi over 4
i
e to the pi over 3
i
and then we have e to the
e to the 5 pi over 12 i 5 pi
over
12 i now we're going to square each of
them it's nice to leave it in this
exponential form when you square it much
easier to square
these values if you square this you're
just essentially multiplying the
exponent times 2. so this is going to be
e to the
pi over 6 i this will be e to the
pi over 3 i we're just squaring them so
we're just taking the square of each of
these
values
each of these roots so e to the pi over
3i and then here you're going to have
e to the
e to the pi over 2i
e to the pi over 2i then over here
you'll have e to the
2 pi over 3 2 pi over 3 i and then
finally over here you'll have e to the 5
pi
5 pi over 6 i now these are the squared
of the squared values of these roots
here now let's just think about their
imaginary parts
let's just think about their imaginary
parts so this guy right over here can be
rewritten
this guy can be rewritten here as cosine
of pi over 6 plus i sine of pi over 6.
so his imaginary part is sine of pi over
6.
this guy's imaginary part same is going
if you expanded out euler's identity
euler's formula cosine of pi over 3 plus
i
sine of pi over 3. so this imaginary
part is just going to be sine
of pi over 3 here's going to be sine of
pi over 2 here's going to be sine of 2
pi over 3 and here's going to be sine of
here it is going to be sine of 5 pi
5 pi over 6
5 pi over 6. now we just have to
evaluate these guys
and take their absolute value
and then take the sum and then multiply
everything times four and we're
essentially in the home stretch so pi
over six pi over six is 180 if we are in
degrees and my brain has easier time
processing that so actually let me draw
another unit circle over here just so we
can visualize these angles
so now we have sine of pi over 6 pi over
6 is the same thing
pi over 6 is the same thing as 30
degrees so it looks like this
and we know that the sine of 30 degrees
the sine of 30 degrees is one half this
is one this is one half this the cosine
is square root of three over two but
this right over here is one half
sine of pi over three
pi over three is the equivalent of 60
degrees
it is the equivalent of 60 degrees the
sine over here is square root of 3 over
2
square root of 3 over 2 you can figure
that out from 30 60 90 triangles then
you have sine of pi over 2.
pi over 2 is that right over there well
the sine of that is is is just one so
this is the imagine it's if it's the
imaginary part of this or i guess this
would be this essentially this evaluates
just to i but the imaginary part which
is viewed as a coefficient on the i
which is kind of non-intuitive you kind
of think it's the whole thing but when
people say the imaginary part so this
will just be
this will just be one and then sine of
two pi
over
three two pi over three let's see that
is so pi over three is 60 degrees so you
could view that as 120 degrees so it's
120 degrees so it's right over here so
it's going to have the same sine value
it's going to have the same sine value
as pi over 3
as pi over 3. so it's going to be square
root of 3 over two
and then sine of five pi over six
pi over six is 30 degrees so this is
sine of 150 degrees so it's going to be
just like that
it's going to have the same sine value
as pi over six so it's going to be one
half and lucky for us these are all
positive values so let's just take the
sum so we have
we have one half
plus one half
is one plus another 1 over here is going
to be 2 plus square root of 3 over 2
plus square root of 3 over 2 is
square root of 3. now remember this was
we just we just did for this quadrant
over here we have to do it for all of
the quadrants so we just need to
multiply we just need to multiply
everything times 4. so the sum
of the absolute value of the imaginary
part of the square
of the square of the roots is 8 plus 4
square roots of three eight plus four
square roots of three and going back to
the original problem
we got the answer here this is eight
plus four square roots of three i don't
wanna make i wanna make sure i didn't
mess it up right eight plus four square
roots of 3. so if you want to find m
plus n plus p it is 8 plus 4 plus 3
which is equal to 15 and we're done